I do have to ask you drastic world 3
what are the chances on a scale of 1 to
10 that we will see you maybe oh I don't
know I I have no idea that's not a no
though right I mean you know I I love
dr. Ellie Sattler so I could never I
could never say no to that in any level
but I really don't know I mean I I don't
even know what they're cooking up yet
have you talked to Chris I met Chris
recently at her restaurant know each
other and it was really funny we ran
into each others arms and hugged each
other like we were family that is so
because we're both hit the same but and
he just seemed fantastic and is
hilarious but but yeah I don't know
anymore
laura dern not ruling out a return to
her Jurassic Park roots that's some
predictability but before that can
happen she's got a new movie out with
Kristen Stewart JT Leroy it's based on
the real story and memoir of Savannah
canoe so just use like your pen name
more like my avatar
Laura's character convinces her
sister-in-law Savannah to become JT when
I first saw you might look like him huh
you guys must have had a blast filming
this I would imagine with like the
accents and the costumes and everything
what did he find most interesting about
one another
I'm worried I have like I'm already
laughing just because she generally like
she's a devil like she's not even the
most like she's like oh yeah like
diplomatic perfect like love buddy
everyone all the time and she is like
genuinely that is who she is yeah but
then she'll also be like oh and by the
way we
hilariously I'm like oh yeah like she's
a quick she's a quick one I felt like I
needed to really stand on my tiptoes
around there well I feel grateful for
that description and then it's only
matched than by I mean I think we found
each other in that place we got to know
each other deeply because they had to be
in such a boundary list place yeah to
get to go through it that all bets were
off in terms of how we got to know each
other what's everything we shared and I
actually would say my favorite thing
about you is you'll go wherever oh yeah
I follow going literally I was like what
are we doing
we laughed hysterically yeah Laura also
has these ndu of big little lies coming
out in June I have to know in the
trailer what is all the screaming in big
little lies about I probably know as
little about that as she know about
Charlie's baby tell me this in the end
of season one you guys are all on this
beach and it seems like you're all at
peace it's season two gonna fill in the
gap of what happens before that
seriously because I'm actually very
curious do you watch me little Ashton I
think we will learn a lot yes okay I do
think there's much to learn
yeah and I think we're gonna be very
excited to see her in Charlie's Angels
oh the Queen of deflection right here
that's what's happening team captain
[Music]
[Applause]